[Musique]
ils ont empêché le conseil de
surveillance de la gms l'hôpital
gérontologique et médico social de
plaisir
les salariés protestent contre la
suppression de postes
espace de choses il ya un plan de
licenciements envisagés par le biais
d'une privatisation de services
soignants 1 qui sont des ash au nombre
de 47 aujourd'hui un essai et s'est
laissé le début puisque demain il y à
des suppressions de lits qui sont
annoncés est ce qui fait qu il y aura
aussi de nouveaux des suppressions de
postes mais alors tous corps confondus
autre sujet de tension la fusion de
l'établissement avec l'hôpital charcot
au 1er janvier 2018
une fusion qui entraînera notamment une
même charte pour les deux centres sur le
temps de travail
les 47 postes quelque chose qui est
décidé les 47 dont fin de contrat dont
vingt reprises
ça c'est pour la gms pour charcot et
pour surtout pour la convergence des
charters et et rien n'est décidé on a
simplement dit et je comprends leur
inquiétude
on a simplement dit aux représentants du
personnel que on ne pourrait pas avoir
une harmonisation massif par le haut
c'est rigoureusement impossible
actuellement 1200 agents travaillent à
la gms 700 à charcot les négociations
ont débuté au mois d'avril
le mouvement se poursuit les salariés
ont appelé à la grève illimitée